m
bonsoir je suis très fier très
impressionné d'être parmi vous ce soir
est reconnaissante au hasard de la vie
qui m'ont fait rencontrer un des
organisateurs je le remercie pour cette
belle soirée
quant au thème de notre conférence la
rupture
j'avoue que ma première réaction ça a
été plutôt questionnement parce que pour
moi quand je pense rupture je pense et
en une et deux seule une des deux filles
de la soirée je pense plutôt rupture
amoureuse ou alors rupture géologique
ce qui n'a rien à voir mais pas
forcément innovation et pourtant quand
on y réfléchit ça a du sens donc tout à
fait vain peu près plus de quinze ans
que je travaille sur le développement
d'un projet innovant et c'est vrai que
je me suis jamais vraiment positionné en
tant que tu t'y futur utilisatrice du
système avec un avant ma galère avec les
pathologies et un après
la possibilité d'utiliser le produit que
je développe mais je vous assure y aura
bien un avant et après et la technologie
dont je vais vous parler va entraîner
une rupture
donc on va essayer à travers ma
présentation dans d'examiner d'un peu
plus près le lien entre rupture et une
ovation
tout cela en regardant le développement
d'un produit de rupture
le henné ou alors au début le début de
l'histoire c'est d'avoir une idée alors
nous on est parti sur une idée un peu
farfelue d'associer deux technologies
complètement différente
la pyrotechnie et la pharmacie la
pyrotechnie dont le coeur de métier est
plutôt d'envoyer des fusées dans
l'espace la pharmacie elle soigne ses
patients pourtant la pyrotechnie ou
matériaux énergétiques a connu un
développement dans les applications
civiles depuis ces vingt dernières
années
je sais qu'on a tendance écolo mais je
pense que la plupart d'entre vous ont
pris leur voiture pour venir ici ce soir
il m'a dans cette voiture il ya
peut-être un airbag et l'airbag est une
technologie pyrotechniques
en fait c'est les matériaux énergétiques
qui vont gonfler le coussin d'air qui va
vous protéger en cas de choc
les sportifs aussi maintenant on leur
système pour les protéger prenant leur
chute
que ce soit les skieurs les et quittant
voire même les marins qui tombe qui
peuvent de façon impromptue tombé dans
l'eau le contact avec l'eau salée peu
gonflé non pas un coussin mais une bouée
pour les maintenir en vie si l'injection
sans aiguille a également une longue
histoire avec 70 également une longue
histoire
à l'époque quand on utilise un gaz
hommes et n'importe quoi on utilise un
ressort qui va la force mécanique de ce
resort va propulser le liquide à travers
un orifice tu faible diamètre
on peut aussi utiliser une petite
bonbonne de gaz sous pression
malheureusement ces dispositifs sont
chères coûteux encombrants est donc très
plus utiliser notre idée a été
d'utiliser justement les matériaux
énergétiques pour miniaturiser ce
dispositif
donc on part d'un dispositif qui va en
fait être déclenchée au moment de nous
on en a besoin on va le prendre
l'appuyer sur le site d'injection et cet
appui va déclencher une réaction
chimique
cette réaction chimique
rappelez vous vos courses chimie va
créer du gaz ce gaz va rester dans un
milieu clos et donc va faire monter la
pression à l'intérieur du système
c'est cette pression qui va entraîner le
mouvement de la colonne de liquide et
qui va pousser le liquide donc le
médicament a injecté à travers des
orifices de très faible diamètre
le g10 équipe qui sort de ces orifices
est suffisamment cohérent pour percer la
peau et transféré le médicament à
l'intérieur du corps je vais vous
montrer une petite vidéo qui va vous
emmener à l'intérieur du dispositif pour
visualiser ce que je viens
vous expliquer y'a pas le feu
donc voilà et comme vous être très
attentif
je veux vous faire une vraie injection
en live je vais essayer donc je prends
un support qu'un support qu'on a
développé au laboratoire qui nous permet
justement de visualiser le litige je
prends mon dispositif dont qui ressemble
à ça il ressemble à rien de vraiment
connu on ne peut pas vraiment comparer
sa forme à quelque chose d'existant on a
beaucoup travaillé sur l'ergonomie du
dispositif puisqu'il faut qu'il soit
simple et facile à utiliser
donc c'est très simple je leur dirai
tout à l'heure mais ya pas de bouton ya
pas de réglage on ouvre le dispositif on
le positionne sur la cible et on injecte
donc en moins d'un dixième de seconde le
médicament et l'intérieur du patient
donc voilà donc la suite avec une idée
avoir avoir une idée avec une seule idée
on va pas très loin
très rapidement en fait il faut générer
des données des résultats et donc ça
c'est la phase qu'on appelle la phase de
preuve de concept d'une des premières
phases de développement d'un produit et
elle a lieu dans un laboratoire de
recherche
forcément quand on travaille sur un
produit qui n'existe pas les méthodes
d'essai ils les mêmes les tests qu'on
pourrait utiliser pour montrer que le
produit fonctionne elle n'existe pas
donc dès cette étape la nouvelle rupture
il faut être créatif développer ses
propres systèmes décès il mettre au
point sa propre analyse des résultats
n'ont donc aux laboratoires
on a travaillé son autre dispositif on
l'a équipé d'un petit capteur de
pression ce qui nous a permis de mesurer
ce qui se passait en interne lors du
fonctionnement
on a également été inventifs sur la
cible à utiliser au laboratoire
puisqu'on a récupéré des échantillons de
peau humaine qui sont issus des labos
des services de chirurgie esthétique
donc c'est des gens qui ont un petit peu
d'embonpoint qui se font enlever un
petit bouddha abdomen et en
reconditionnant cela aux laboratoires ça
nous permet vraiment d'avancé sur le
développement de dispositifs
ça nous a permis de commencer le
dimensionnement des composants comment
aussi de dévaluer leur tenue mécanique
et d'affiner le traitement du profil de
pression donc grâce à une maquette
relativement robuste et à un implant
d'expérience évidemment efficace on a
rapidement eu par rapidement après
quelques mois tout de même une première
configuration notre système et cette
première configuration nous a permis de
montrer que notre idée était pertinente
qu'on pouvait utiliser les matériaux
énergétiques et cette réaction chimique
pour injecter la bonne dose de
médicaments au bon endroit et donc ça
pouvait constituer une tamment pour les
patients mais aussi pour les médecins
une rupture puisque en fait
le patient peut lui-même ce auto injecté
il n'y a plus besoin d'un environnement
de médical d'un professionnel de santé
d'une formation
le système comme je voulais montrer est
simple on ouvre on appuie sur le site
d'injection et l'injection est réalisé
ça peut considérer pour des indications
ça peut être considéré comme pour des
indications comme une véritable rupture
ça peut aussi permettre à andy
laboratoire de mieux gérer le cycle de
vie de leurs médicaments et pour les
patients il n'y a plus de stress lee
à l'éguille ni à l'injection c'est pour
ça que ça s'est vite orientée vers les
actionnaires vers les indications
d'urgence en effet on a rarement une
crise d'épilepsie quand on a un rendez
vous avec son médecin généraliste
on a également rarement une crise de
migraine
généralement elle pointe son nez quand
on s'y attend le moins et les chocs
anaphylactiques liés à des allergies que
ce soit alimentaire ou liées aux
insectes bain en général les arrive
quand on se promène loin dans la forêt
mais rarement dans un environnement de
santé donc c'est ça qui nous a orientés
vers les implications d'urgence car le
patient peut lui-même sous-tend injecté
et rapidement trouver une solution pour
gérer sa crise
donc on en était au fait que l'idée
était là on avait commencé à développer
le produit dont vous pouvez passer un
autre pan de merveilleux du
développement le dossier réglementaire
et la nouvelle rupture c'est plus de
dire en effet un médicament qui n'existe
pas il n'est pas référencée dans toutes
les normes et poule arsenal
pharmaceutique réglementaire il faut
encore une fois se montrer créatif
utiliser une partie des données croisées
les bibliographies faire une analyse des
documents existants mais en les adaptant
un petit peu à l'innovation
c'est vraiment un vraie démarche
intellectuelle innovantes en rupture
qu'il faut initier
si on fait le point à cette étape là on
a donc des preuves d'essai avec toute
une banque de données de résultats
une application avec na des indications
enfin 10 des utilisateurs bien
identifiés et un dossier réglementaire
qu'on a un petit peu de mal à monter
mais on arrive tant bien que mal à
mouthe dans ce dossier de réglementaire
une grosse partie concerne la fiabilité
et la sûreté du dispositif évidemment on
s'adresse à un public très particulier
qui est un public malades
donc il faut pas soupe et surtout quand
il ya là la vie qui est en jeu il faut
vraiment avoir une fiabilité à son porte
donc on commence à penser à
développement de l'outil de fabrication
et la tiare nouvelle rupture parce
qu'évidemment les machines pour
fabriquer des composants qui n'existe
pas elle n'existe pas suivi donc
nouvelle étape créative
il faut développer notre propre machine
est internalisé certains process il faut
également convaincre les fournisseurs de
se lancer avec nous dans la monture
il faut que faut aussi trouver des
prestataires suffisamment courageux pour
nous accompagner
et on a aussi pris le risque
d'internaliser certains processus
stratégiques pour en fait mettre notre
terrain industriel en place et faire que
quelque part il soit unique au monde
donc si on reprend le fil et si vous
pensez tout cela à tous les objets que
vous croisez dans votre quotidien
à toutes les étapes qu'il faut mettre en
place qu'il faut suivre pour mettre en
place une idée prouver que l'idée est
une bonne idée qu'on va pouvoir la
fabrique et qu'on va pouvoir l'utiliser
en respectant la réglementation
eh ben on peut dire que la rupture est
un vrai combat coûte quotidien que dès
la feuille blanche jusqu'à la mise sur
le marché
il faut tout le temps tout le temps ce
challenge et trouver des nouvelles idées
pour pouvoir répondre à tout un tas de
d'exigence liés à la conception d'un
produit
donc il faut que montrer qu'il est une
bonne idée
et donc ça eh ben il faut aussi penser à
tous les hommes qui sont derrière ces
idées dont la vie la passion est de
développer une petite pensée iron mask
et c'est vraiment important de
comprendre que ça peut prendre aussi du
temps et écouter beaucoup d'argent si je
reviens sur
produits du quotidien vous la regardez
votre portable avec toutes ces idées en
tête et je pense que vous serez beaucoup
beaucoup plus compréhensif on tient un
petit soucis de fonctionnement parce qu
en fait derrière cet avatar il ya
beaucoup beaucoup d'énergie dépensée de
la sueur pour que l'innovation puisse
servir notre quotidien je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]